(triumphant music)
- We're here at the TCL Chinese Theater
on historic Hollywood Boulevard,
otherwise known as the Walk of Fame.
(people cheering)
So my grandfather, his
name is John Barrymore.
He had a sister and a brother
named Ethel and Lionel
and they were known as the Barrymores.
And he was also known
as the great profile,
or as he called it, pro-feel.
He actually put his face in the cement
and it's the only one here that has it.
But because he was known for his profile,
which I'm lucky enough to have inherited,
I am gonna do something I
always do when I come here.
(whimsical orchestral music)
And sometimes our family isn't here.
Although we didn't get to be together,
I've taken on the responsibility
to keep carrying out their
name and keep it alive.
So this tiny piece of cement
is a way to stay close to him.
And it means a lot to me.
It's as close as I'm gonna get to him.
(upbeat music)